the Biden Administration and western
states that depend on the Colorado River
have struck a deal on cutting water use
until 2026. the agreement would reduce
water siphoned from the Colorado by more
than 3.6 trillion cubic meters
California which uses the largest share
of Colorado River water would bear the
brunt of the cuts with about one-third
of the total Arizona and Nevada also
agreed to significant Cuts other states
that rely on the river are Colorado New
Mexico and Utah experts say the
agreement is a stopgap measure so
essentially it's a kind of like saying
we're going to keep doing this more
aggressive conservation for the next
three years till we get to 2026 and in
the meantime we're going to keep
negotiating uh the the big deal that
we're expecting in 2026. 23 years of
drought worsened by human-caused climate
change have left reservoirs like Lake
Mead the country's largest dangerously
low the lake is at about 30 percent
capacity
heavy rain and snow in the west early
this year gave the Colorado and its
reservoirs a desperately needed surge of
water but scientists and climate change
experts say the river is simply not big
enough to serve all the demands the
Region's growing population have placed
on it the agreement is a first step to
avert a crisis but not a long-term
solution will it be enough
only time will tell we'll have to see if
we have
um we have another year of super poor
runoff
uh the the agreement itself acknowledges
that we could be in that danger zone
again lasting Solutions include
conserving water and modernizing cities
farms and infrastructure to use less Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles